we have to finish the whole thing yeah
that's why I brought you guys
yo that's crazy let's go wreck oh my God
what is happening
it's really spicy
oh my
what's up everyone it's Esther welcome
to my spicy Journey this is a show about
my love and hopefully your love for all
things spicy food I'm a very proud New
Yorker but I just landed in LA and of
course had to hit up my favorite part of
town duh K-Town baby we're gonna eat our
way around K-Town traditionally you kind
of like hop around and that's what I
love to do it just first up icha seconds
up third stop we're going to
hanjinpochan getting some spicy chicken
feet icha we're gonna go meet up with my
friends Matt and Grace and eat some
spicy crab and sometimes we're going to
Yap dog and doing a spicy taco challenge
hey town baby let's go
[Music]
I've been craving chicken feet for the
longest time and this is the only spot
in the US that you can get really good
chicken feet well in my opinion at least
see
that's how you eat it
yes yeah oh my God I haven't had it for
months I'm so excited this place is
Iconic it is crazy popular I've been to
the one in Korea when I heard that they
opened one in La I freaked out since
then that was a few years ago I've been
coming here every single time I'm in La
this is not somewhere you go on a date I
mean if you do he's a keeper or she's a
keeper whatever I'm bringing you guys on
the journey also this is not the outfit
to wear when you're eating spicy chicken
feet but it's where's the button this is
very typical in a Korean restaurant
there's a service button excuse me
when you come here you only order one
thing
so they're known for their spicy chicken
feed it's called takbar this place
specializes specifically on this dish I
feel like my spice tolerance is kind of
crazy I can take a lot of heat I know
famous last words so I haven't had it
for a while so we'll see
you know
the actual temperature of the dish has
to be boiling hot it's just more
enjoyable you know you just want to burn
the [__] out of your mouth is
foreign
this is the greatest compliment to this
dish because there's mayo and that's
supposed to cool down your mouth
I'm gonna put the gloves on typically
what you do is you make little balls and
that's called
sometimes I'm too lazy and I just eat it
oh my God I'm a little nervous about my
white outfit that I decided to wear to
eat red food I'm a professional it looks
insane right oh my God it looks so good
my mouth is starting to water right now
at my restaurant we make a lot of broths
and our chicken stock
is like 50 made with chicken feet
there's so much collagen and honestly it
makes the best broth it's like so sticky
that's spicy see that's spicy
foreign
I think I have to get used to the heat a
little it's a little it's spicy
like I said
by no means is this an elegant meal it
does look a little disturbing doesn't it
all right
what is this for
is it the bucket there's bones in every
single feet I mean think about it it's
beef it's bony it's not the most
Pleasant thing to look at but I'm
telling you it's delicious
it's so good
I've had a lot of my friends come and
eat this with me I must say no one's
like really down for it
once you get into it it is [__] so
good you know I'm so hot
my Soldier has a little chicken feet in
it
it's the perfect compliment Soju some
spicy chicken feet Soju again chicken
feed it's like a love language
thank you
continuing on our spicy K-Town Journey
we're on to Ita we're going to which
specializes in fermented crab we're
gonna dig in on some crabs let's go
hi
thanks for joining me hello
we like its pastry
extra I got the spicy one and then
regular just so we can have a comparison
we're Korean you can handle it you can
handle anything I think this is the best
Korean restaurant in America like a
traditional Korean restaurant I think
everything that I've tried this is my
favorite really crazy coming from that
yeah no right because Matt you're like
the king of Koreatown you've eaten
everything you've tried everything I
think I saw this like K-pop thing on
Tick Tock where this K-pop Star was like
I think the Korean food in La is better
than in Korea and I don't think that's
like oh true but like you can find
really really good Korean food here I go
to Korea a lot I love the food and
Korean obviously it's the birthplace
it's Korea of course the food's good
there's like millions of restaurants but
that's the problem because there's so
many restaurants you can walk in yeah
you can walk into a bad place yeah
whereas L.A everything's kind of
concentrated it has to be good to
survive and this place
in general the crabs Young
tank kimchi
is the little side dishes you get in a
Korean restaurant it's usually seasonal
pickles kimchi oh that looks really
small that looks amazing
oh my God
thank you
is it spicy wait how do I get it oh it's
got to cook yeah so Quezon is a
fermented crab usually in a soy brine or
a spicy gochujang grind it's fermented
for a few days and the flesh kind of
turns a little gelatinous
super delicious it has the most
Umami and it comes from the crab kind of
like eating
fish sauce crazy intense depth of flavor
the real special kedong is definitely
the soy one because that's where you can
really have the eggs and it's kind of
like the more traditional kind when you
didn't have like real nice crabs you
would then kind of cut it up and make
the spicy version and hide all the
imperfections yeah there's so much meat
inside so much meat and you know you can
literally squeeze it out and just
oh
this is which is a spicy crab different
flavor profile but similar flesh
[Music]
right and then that with the spicy sauce
the spicy sauce is like kind of sweet
I mean the crab itself is really sweet
but then the sauce has like doesn't it
taste like some apple maybe oh man the
chili is really intense
this is one of the best burgers I've
ever had it is delicious the thing with
Korean spice is like it's maybe not as
intense but it has a slow burn it keeps
building it's not immediate yeah it's
very like deep it's like more fermented
well-rounded very very balanced what is
that balance that you're trying to
achieve with like a particular Korean
marinade or sauce usually you want the
balance between a salty and the spice
and you want umami and you want
sweetness
so I think that the fermentation
combined with the spice makes Korean
food very unique my like nose is running
yeah me too I'm like I have to pull my
nose
man I need more napkins
thanks guys yeah
how fun so now we're going to do this
spicy food challenge we'll have fun I
ate there once and my face was vibrating
and that's never happened to me before I
have a pretty high spice tolerance but
there's spices on another level the kind
of spicy food that you're going into I
don't touch that
oh my God
place
and they look spicy okay meeting up with
my friends wreck and Rick we are going
to yup doc I'm a little nervous they're
gonna handle it see look at those boys
they can definitely handle this what's
up guys oh oh my God
yo what's up
you know oh yeah that's true K-Town
style that's the true greeting right the
90 degrees you know should we do it to
the camera let's do it okay
what should we say yeah
okay
this is
the place of really really bizarrely
spicy rice cakes okay
I'm nervous
[Music]
I feel like we have to do the highest
yeah yeah like hello if I don't taste
sweat and hair product it's a failure
today you know what I mean like that's
I'm ready I'm just letting you know
right now we're gonna we're here for the
challenge it's like a friendship type of
dish you know what I mean yeah like
after a concert you eat it on the
streets yes yeah in Korea like you know
you're on your way home
um after school you go to tapakistan
yeah I mean that's my memories of eating
Taco yeah it was always with my
girlfriend and we would always eat it
after school what is it about bubblegis
just like it's so chewy it's chewy it's
spicy and I think that Korean girls do
really like spicy food like it's a thing
but it's also because it de-stresses you
right or we're going for it we're doing
the challenge
you see the eyes his pupils this show is
called heat eaters I want my uh soul to
lift out of my body yeah talk to me
about spicy challenges you guys have
done your fair share of spicy challenges
have you ever done like eating ones like
you know how in Korea they do a lot of
yeah oh we have to finish the whole
thing yeah duh that's why I brought you
guys I mean that's like the real thing
about mokbang it's like the amount of
food you eat it's not just about the
spiciness you know people think mukbang
is all about like just eating in front
of camera no mukbang is you have to
challenge yourself yeah or show some
something like that's not really seen
that's what makes it a challenge because
yeah anyone can take you know a tiny
bite of something it's spicy because it
goes away but can you eat the entire
thing why are you doing this
why
did you start this journey Esther okay
we love spicy food yeah that much like
that much would you order this challenge
like post-mates to your crib like where
you buy no not really yeah you do it
because you want to suffer together and
create a font you know I'm nervous
because I've been readjusting my advice
already I'm calm man my butthole's been
through the wall
any last words or what pray to your Gods
I'm ready to the spice Lords
amen
wow
so we have doc which is these rice cakes
which are fish cakes there's some
cabbage and this is what we ordered it
with which is
which is the Chinese flat noodles and
this is very trendy yeah I've never seen
that before oh yeah that's a very very
trendy shade right okay that looks like
it softs up all the hot sauce like all
the mukbang girls it's all about the
flat yeah yeah and then we have the
assorted to him which is the tempura
yeah yeah oh and this is
which is basically seaweed rice rolled
with um some noodles inside all right so
topuki traditionally made with
it's fermented so it's that more deep
spice it's more like flavorful spice
yeah but yup duck special because they
have like eight different types of chili
powders and then it's a blend of them
and then they add that to the top okay
and that's what makes it really spicy
and they use
and you guys know it's a spiciest Korean
chili yeah yeah yeah the real spicy one
I don't know
yeah yeah it's it's kind of kind of like
equivalent to ghost pepper and they take
that ground it up and add that to this
which is gonna give it that real intense
heat yeah cheers
oh
[Music]
okay initial thoughts
it's delicious
whoa It's coming
oh
yeah yeah I know right away that we look
at the first of all look at the workers
they're nervous for us
[Music]
remember guys
it's not about the initial bite it's
about eating the whole thing I got you
I'm with it now it's delicious
[Music]
laughs
okay second bite and I'm dying a little
cholo kimchi muddy
bear no matter
I'm seeing like flashes of my ancestors
right now oh holy moly this is not
it builds up it's the build you got the
little pokeballs going on I have no
expression right now I'm thinking about
all the times I've been forgiven
I should have been forgiven for
I'm clubbing already [__] up you know
that coffin it goes into your nose
thank you
all right let's go wreck taking one for
the team
hold on
oh my God
that's what I did WOW set the stage yo
my cheeks hurt yeah you want the water
there's some water I'm drinking water
full
the milk
so what having white parents would be
like
yourself a pat on the back
yup yo that's crazy yo that's crazy
I go what is happening ladies and
gentlemen I always wanted to be our
first sweet Beast you thought I was
going to come correct let's go
wait hold on that's something my eye
hold on hold on let's go baby my brother
in Christ
wow
it's my [__] boy right there are you
[__] serious let's go
you see for real
oh my God
Hallelujah
that's
insane ladies and gentlemen my name is
Bob Ross
follow me on yak's rig while X
underscore Rick all right
I want to see how these are thousand
followers
did it he did it four thousand dollars
yeah
that's a that's a W for Korea
Korea hell yeah I did it for Korea baby
we did it
take out beef on Netflix
follow me at Rex dizzy uh yeah follow me
Rex is the audience yeah when I'm not
doing this I rap I'm in a crew called
year the ox me and my partner Jay Young
[__] you mean do I really rap Korean
[__] with the flow like old
[__] delivered the whole show with the
notion of blowing this whole [__] up
we're bringing up my culture with us
raxter boy Esther Choi connective voice
you know what I mean lungs fine but the
rest destroyed it's [__] Yaks
rig baby let's go
Champion over here my Left Eye's
twitching is that normal I don't think
anything today was
everything you did you got it dude
[Music]
you're the champion man
I knew you had it in you bro
[Music]
my organs are trembling
hey guys it's Esther from heat eaters
thanks for watching
that was spicy
please like And subscribe and to watch
more episodes click here